une inflation qui flirte avec les 10%
l'espagne n'avait plus connu de telles
hausses des prix depuis près de quatre
décennies la guerre en ukraine est
passée par là elle a provoqué en un peu
plus d'un mois une flambée des prix de
l'énergie et une augmentation du coût
des produits alimentaires alors pour
limiter la casse le gouvernement de
pedro sanchez adopter un vaste plan
national avec des mesures d'urgence
le gouvernement s'engage à tout faire
pour diminuer ses effets sur la
population
avec un plan de 6 milliards d'euros
d'investissements jusqu'au 30 juin à
travers des aides directes des baisses
d'impôts en plus des 10 milliards
d'euros qui vont être transférés sur la
forme de crédits pour amortir les
conséquences de la crise sur les
familles et sur les entreprises
cette enveloppe budgétaire prendra la
forme de subvention de 20 centimes
d'euros par litre de carburant d'une
hausse de 15% du revenu minimum versé
aux espagnols les plus modestes et d'un
allégement des factures d'électricité
car le gouvernement est sous pression
depuis plusieurs semaines agriculteurs
pêcheurs et routiers notamment ont
investi la rue par dizaines de milliers
pour protester contre la cherté de la
vie
et en mange à la rue là on est en train
d'être ruinés ils nous volent ils
veulent quand soit faible mais restera
courageuses aujourd'hui les gens mon
mari était au lab éléments là s'il ne
trouve pas de solution il n'y aura pas
de camion
ces mesures ne sont pas suffisantes
dans un mois les prix des carburants
vont augmenter peut-être passer à 2
euros 10 litres alors les 20 centimes
seront inutiles une grogne sociale que
le gouvernement espère calmer avec son
plan de riposte nationale et grâce à
l'accord conclu à bruxelles pour fixer
un prix de référence pour le gas